>>> HEY, DYLAN?
TAKE THE LIP RING OUT.
IT'S AGAINST COMPANY POLICY.
>> THIS ONE'S GOING OUT TO ALL
THE CORPORATE DRONES OUT THERE.
>> WORKING FOR THE MAN, MAKING
OTHER PEOPLE RICH.
>> WAIT, THE ALMIGHTY DOLLAR.
>> YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
LISTEN UP.
♪ MOM AND DAD SAID
GO GET A JOB
GO WORK REAL HARD
GO PUNCH YOUR CLOCK ♪
♪ CLIMB THE CORPORATE
LADDER STRAIGHT TO THE TOP
BE A DUDE SOMEDAY ♪
♪ YO, BE THE BOSS
BUT WHITE COLLAR LIFE
DON'T WORK IT SEEMS
'CAUSE I AINT NO ♪
♪ CORPORATE WORKER BEE
EVERYBODY IN THE HOUSE
WHO FEEL LIKE ME ♪
♪ GET UP ON YOUR FEET
AND SCREAM
TAKE THIS JOB AND
SHOVE IT UP YOUR ♪
♪ I WILL NEVER BE
PART OF THIS MACHINE
CORPORATE SOCIETY ♪
♪ YOU CAN'T HOLD ME BACK
WITH A PAYCHECK
THIS JOB CAN KISS MY ASS
>> HEY, TINA, GREAT WORK ON THAT
COMPETE ANALYSIS.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> YOU SHOULD THINK ABOUT THE
MANAGEMENT TRAINING PROGRAM.
WE COULD USE SOMEONE LIKE YOU ON
THE 12th FLOOR.
>> WOW.
I WILL.
THANK YOU, SIR.
>> GREAT WORK.
♪ BOSS MAN SIT AROUND
ON HIS ASS ALL DAY
DOING REAL GOOD WORK
FOR THE COMPANY ♪
♪ HE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S UP
BUT HE ACTUALLY DOES
SO WHAT'S UP BEING ♪
♪ UPSTAIRS AND TAKE, YO
WELL, THE HOURS ARE GOOD
AND THE PAY IS GENEROUS
CORPORATE CULTURE ♪
♪ STRAIGHT UP VENOMOUS
BUT OUR BENEFITS
>> OH, ALL RIGHT.
ONE SECOND.
I JUST GOT TO MAKE SURE I RSVP
FOR THIS MEETING.
YEP, I KNEW IT AND --
[ PHONE CHIME ]
♪ CAUSE THE PEOPLE
AT THIS PLACE ARE MY
BEST FRIENDS ♪
♪ AND WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BOSS, HE'S MY
BEST FRIEND ♪
♪ TAKE THIS JOB AND
SHOVE IT UP YOUR --
>> TINA, NATE, CASPER, YOU GOT A
SEC?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH.
>> UH-HUH.
>> SURE THING, TED.
♪ I WILL NEVER GO
DOWN THE CORPORATE
ROAD ♪
♪ A NIGHTMARE
NOTHING, BUT A --
BLAH BLAH BLAH --
>> HOW DO I ACT AS IF WE WOULD
PITCH ON THE DIGITAL CAMPAIGN?
>> YEAH, IT'S PRETTY COOL,
ACTUALLY.
>> YEAH, IT'S REALLY NICE THAT
TED IS LOOKING AT IDEAS
INTERNALLY.
♪ YOU CORPORATE DRONES
IN YOUR SUITS AND TIES
THE BOSS SAYS, JUMP ♪
♪ YOU SAY HOW HIGH
>> TED WANTS TO WORK ON IT TOO.
♪ LET'S DIVE RIGHT IN
PUT OUR HEADS TOGETHER
OR DIE THE WHOLE THING
MAKE A GOOD IDEA BETTER
LET'S ORDER FOOD ♪
♪ STAY HERE ALL NIGHT
IF WE'RE PICKING TO PAY
IT'S GONNA BE TIGHT ♪
♪ IF WE DO THIS RIGHT
WHO KNOWS WHERE WE
COULD GO ♪
♪ TINA IS RETIRED
AND SHE'LL NEED TO
BE REPLACED, YO ♪
♪ ONE OF US COULD
GET HER JOB
MANAGEMENT POSITION
DOWN THE ROAD WE COULD BE
RUNNING THIS DIVISION ♪
♪ PERFECT QUESTIONS
PERFECT PRESENTATION
DON'T CHOKE IT
♪ GOT A FOOT IN THE DOOR
NO ONES KICKING OPEN
>> WORK HARD, GOOD THINGS WILL
COME.
>> THAT'S JUST HOW IT IS,
PEOPLE.
>> DO IT.
LIP RING.